[Music]  our earth this is our home and home to  millions of other species there is no  separation the air you breathe in is the  air phytoplankton and trees breathe out  your mom birthed you her mom  births her and up and up the lineage  until one we all come from the one you  can call it the Big Bang you can call it  creation you can call it God source  infinite consciousness we are here not  as an accident  why we deposit this incredible adventure  as an accident don't allow this  nihilistic first principled mistake  there is deep purpose and meaning to  this  for us to experience fun adventure in  consciousness for us too  the illusion of separation for us to  creatively express ourselves is material  spiritual world  Oh  alive marry science and spirit  steward this earth  steward each other  kindness and abundance for all is our  you